people often say you don't need to know
any math to program a computer and
that's truthy however any sufficiently
advanced technology is indistinguishable
from Magic but magic isn't real math
Explains It All developers often avoid
learning math because it looks scary but
it actually makes complicated magic like
computer graphics and neural networks
easier to understand and not just that
but it unlocks the secrets of the entire
physical Universe there's a few abstract
math concepts for programmers that you
just can't ignore and understanding them
will make you think more like a true
engineer I'm no math genius in fact I'm
the opposite which makes me uniquely
qualified to teach 10 essential math
concepts using memes and other visual
aids that almost anybody can understand
the first person who survives until the
end and cracks the code will win this
one of a kind Balenciaga fireship hoodie
let's jump right into topic number one
Boolean algebra which is used almost
every time you write code a Boolean is a
binary variable that can have two
possible values true or false now there
are three operators that you can use to
work with them and or in not or
conjunction disjunction and negation if
you want to be fancy imagine you're
trying to get a girlfriend we can use
the Boolean variables of rich and
handsome to describe you if you're both
rich and handsome you'll definitely get
a girlfriend but if you're not rich and
not handsome you'll have to pay for an
only Fan's girlfriend if you're rich or
handsome you can still get a girlfriend
but your selection is more limited we
can represent this logic and code with
things like if statements but we can
also do it visually with Venn diagrams
like you've been doing since grade
school and you can also create truth
tables like this one here which comes in
handy in zombie apocalypse type
situations but that brings us to concept
2 numeral systems like base 2 throughout
history humans have come up with all
kinds of clever ways to count things but
almost all of them use base 10 like the
10 fingers on your hands like in the
number 423 the four is in the hundreds
place which represents four times one
hundred the two is in the tens place or
two times ten then the final number is
multiplied by one but computers work off
of a base 2 numeral system in base 2
things work the exact same way but
because we only have two symbols to work
with each place is multiplied by two
like two four eight sixteen Thirty 32 64
128 and so on now that you understand
that you also understand how other bases
work like base 16 or hexadecimal which
uses the digits 0 through 9 along with a
through F and is commonly used to
represent binary values in a more
concise way because each hexadecimal
digit can translate into four bits and
you also have base64 which introduces
even more letters and symbols to encode
binary values allowing developers to
represent binary data like an image as a
string of text while computers use base
2 under the hood they still need to
represent base 10 numbers for humans and
the most common way to do that is with
floating Point numbers go ahead and
execute 0.1 plus 0.2 in your favorite
programming language the result should
be
0.30004 How could a computer make such a
silly mistake
well in science numbers can get very big
when talking about space and very small
when talking about things like atoms we
don't write these numbers out completely
and instead use scientific notation
where an exponent raises it to an
approximate value making the number
appear far more concise computers use a
similar approach with floating Point
numbers because they only have a limited
amount of space either 32 bits for
single Precision or 64 for double
Precision which is the default in
languages like Python and JavaScript
it's called a floating point because
there's no fixed number of digits before
or after the decimal point allowing
developers to make a trade-off between
range and precision some numbers like
.01 can't be represented perfectly as a
binary floating point which is the
reason we get those tiny rounding errors
now that you know how numbers work we
can start talking about logarithmic
functions which you might remember from
algebra class to understand them think
of an actual log the log starts at 16
feet then we saw it in half over and
over again until we reach a length of 2.
notice how when we try to draw a line
through it it's not perfectly straight
but rather it curves gradually in
computer science this is how many
algorithms work like binary search
what's interesting though is that if we
know how many times we cut the log we
can raise 2 to the power of that value
in this case 4 to get the original
length of the log that's called
exponentiation and logarithm is the
exact opposite imagine we don't know the
exponent we only know the original
length and want to figure out how many
times we'd have to cut the log to get a
length of 2 we could calculate that with
a base 2 log on the original length
returning a value of 4 when it's base 2
it's called a binary logarithm however
in math it's more common to use base 10
which is called the common logarithm
that'll come in handy but now let's
shift gears to set theory a set is just
an unordered collection of unique values
the best example is a relational
database where each table is a set of
unique rows these tables can be joined
together in a variety of different ways
based on set theory like to select
records that match on both tables you do
an inner join which is called an
intersection and set theory or to grab
all matching records from both tables
you do a full outer join which is a
union and set theory when doing left and
right joins these concepts are combined
like by combining an intersection with
the difference between the two sets now
one thing that's important to notice at
this point is that we're talking about
structures that have a finite number of
elements which falls under the umbrella
of discrete math as opposed to
continuous math like geometry and
calculus that deal with real numbers and
approximations and that brings us to our
next discrete topic com combinatorics
simply put this is all about counting
things especially when combining sets
into combinations or permutations like
if you have an app like Tinder you might
need to count all the possible
combinations of matches as part of a
more complex algorithm that figures out
what to show the end user where maybe
you're building a globally distributed
database and need to figure out how many
database partitions you'll need around
the world ultimately it's all about
understanding how patterns can emerge
what you're looking at here is the
formula for the Fibonacci sequence a
great exercise is to write a function
that generates it congrats bro you just
did combinatorics and unlock the secrets
of the universe engineers at Google use
the same kind of logic to render tiles
on tools like Google Maps and the gods
use this pattern all over the place in
nature combinatorics is closely related
to graph Theory a graph has two basic
parts nodes or vertices and edges that
connect them together like a person
might be a node and an edge might be a
relationship that connects them together
like you love your mom and your mom
loves you back this is an undirected
graph because the relationship goes both
ways however you might also love your
only Fan's girlfriend but this would be
a directed graph because that
relationship only goes One Way edges can
also be weighted meaning one
relationship is more important than the
other if a node can Traverse back to
itself it's called cyclic otherwise it's
known as acyclic as a programmer you'll
often need to build graphs from the
ground up but more importantly know how
to Traverse them like when using
dijkstra's algorithms you find the most
efficient way to navigate through
traffic but before you start writing
graph traversal algorithms you should
know a little bit about complexity
Theory which can tell us in theory how
much time and memory an algorithm should
use we use Big O notation to express
complexity and when talking about time
the input represents the number of steps
it will take to complete a task like if
we read a single element from an array
that would give us o of 1 or constant
time which is extremely fast and simple
if we need to Loop over an array that
would give us o of n where n is the
length of the array but if for each
iteration in that Loop we Loop over the
same array again that would give us o of
N squared which would be far less
efficient however more sophisticated
algorithms like binary search cut the
search area in half after each iteration
providing us with logarithmic time
understanding how to measure complexity
is essential for technical interviews
and is just a good thing to think about
in general but now let's move away from
discrete math and talk about statistics
which is crucial if you want to do
anything with artificial intelligence
because machine learning is kind of just
a fancy way of doing statistics like
when you type in a chat GPT it generates
a response based on the probability that
it fits the prompt provided by the user
at the very least you should understand
mean median and mode and how standard
deviation indicates how close values in
a set are correlated to the mean there's
a ton to learn beyond that but what I
found especially useful is the
difference between linear regression and
logistic regression in a linear
regression the goal is to predict a
continuous value like the amount of
money you'll lose after buying a stock
the relationship between the input and
output variable is linear and the idea
is to find a line that best fits the
data set however logistic regression is
used for an entirely different set of
problems like classification maybe an
app that predicts if an image is a hot
dog or not a hot dog in this case the
relationship is not linear but rather a
sigmoid function which might predict the
probability that a Boolean variable is
true or false and that brings us to our
final and most difficult topic linear
algebra which comes into play in things
like computer graphics and deep neural
networks to comprehend it you'll need to
understand three weird words scalar is a
single numeric value a vector is a list
of numbers like a one-dimensional array
and finally a matrix is like a grid or
two-dimensional array that contains rows
and Columns of numeric values what's
cool is that vectors can represent
points and directions in a 3D space
while matrices can represent
Transformations that happen to these
vectors when you move a player around in
a video game the lighting and shadows
and the graphics change magically but
it's not magic it's linear algebra
that's being distributed on your GPU
imagine you have a 2d Vector that's at
0.2 X 3y it represents a single point in
an image we can perform linear
Transformations here like scaling
translation rotation shear and so on
let's imagine we now want to scale the
point to a value of 4X 6y we can
represent the scaling factors in a
matrix then represent the point as a
column vector and now we can use matrix
multiplication to scale the point to its
Target location operations like this are
also essential in things like
cryptography such as RSA encryption and
are also essential in deep neural
networks which use vectors to represent
features then use matrix multiplication
to propagate values between nodes in the
network the underlying math is
surprisingly simple but requires a
massive amount of computing power to
handle the Staggering amount of data
required as you can see now math is
actually not that complicated and the
more you study it the more the computer
will reveal its magic tricks thanks for
watching and I will see you in the next
one